[Music]
welcome back so we're talking about the
singular value decomposition how you can
take a data matrix X and write it as the
product of three matrices u Sigma and V
transpose where essentially u contains
information about the column space of X
V contains information about the row
space of X and Sigma is a diagonal
matrix that tells you how important the
various columns of U and V are so
they're hierarchically arranged so that
V u one is more important than u two is
more important than u 3 and so on and so
forth
same with V and the importance is
encoded in these singular values Sigma
notice that I've rewritten V transpose
as as this matrix here so I take the
actual kind of columns of V V 1 V 2 V 3
and I transpose them so now they're row
vectors V 1 transpose V 2 transpose and
so on and so forth this will be a little
bit easier to understand the next part
of this now I should mention that
because this X matrix only has m columns
there are only M linearly independent
columns in this n dimensional subspace
vector space that could be spanned by
these and so only the first M columns of
U are important in representing this
data
okay so we'll come back to that in a
minute so what I want to show you now
there's two things the first one is
going to be how we can represent this
expansion as a sum of rank one matrices
and then in the next segment I'm going
to talk about how you can actually
compute these and interpret them as
encoding correlation structures within
this data matrix X ok so x equals based
on the singular value decomposition what
I can think of is u times Sigma because
this is a diagonal matrix if I take u
times Sigma essentially u1 gets scaled
by Sigma 1
it only gets multiplied by Sigma 1
because every other term in this column
is 0 so if I take that and multiply it
it multiplies this by Sigma 1 all of the
others by 0 same with the second column
it gets 0
you 1 plus Sigma 2 u 2 plus zeros of
everything else and so on and so forth
so this essentially is signify multiply
this I get Sigma 1 u 1 Sigma 2 u 2 and
so on and so forth and then similarly if
I take that matrix and I multiply it by
this V transpose matrix the first column
Sigma 1 u 1 only multiplies the V 1
transpose column the second column only
multiplies the V 2 transpose column and
so forth and so what I end up getting is
an expansion that looks like Sigma 1 u 1
V 1 transpose that's the first column is
this times this times this plus Sigma 2
u 2 V 2 transpose and I encourage you to
actually you know multiply this out this
times this and then that times this and
you'll see that you get this expansion
Sigma 1 u 1 V 1 plus Sigma 2 u 2 V 2
plus dot dot dot eventually you'll get
Sigma M u M V M transpose and here's
where it gets gets interesting even
though this u matrix has n columns so
it's a massive N by n matrix there are
only M nonzero singular values because
this thing can only have at most rank M
there's only n linearly independent rows
and columns of this data matrix X and so
even though I could keep writing this
out plus Sigma M plus 1 u n plus 1 and
so on and so forth
all of those singular values are 0 so
everything after the first M columns of
U and V get multiplied by a 0 so I can
throw all of those away and essentially
what that means is that I can select
just the first M columns of U the first
M by n block in Sigma and the N by n
matrix V and that equals we're gonna
call this u hat Sigma hat and I actually
didn't do anything to V it didn't change
at all v
Transpo's okay so you hat and Sigma hat
are just the first are columns of M
columns of U and the first M by M block
of Sigma and V is the original the
original V matrix and this is exact x is
equal to u Sigma V transpose and it's
also exactly equal to u hat Sigma hat V
transpose where these are just the first
M columns of U and the first M by M
matrix of nonzero singular values okay
this is often called the economy SVD and
it's actually what you want to do in
almost all cases especially where you
have tall skinny matrices I've been
assuming the whole time for the whole
time in these lectures what I've been
assuming is that n is much much larger
than M meaning I have a lot more
measurements maybe a megapixel million
measurements in each column I have many
more many more entries in each column
than I have number of columns so maybe I
have a million pixels per column but
I've only got a few hundred or a
thousand people so this would be a
million this would be a thousand that's
what I've been assuming and in that case
you want to run the economy SVD so in
MATLAB again this is you s v equals SVD
of X but now you give it the econ option
okay and what that does is instead of
returning this massive n by n you matrix
with all of the complete basis all n
columns of U what it does is it only
returns the first M columns of U that
are corresponding to this part that have
nonzero singular values okay good so you
want to expand your X in terms of these
rank one matrices so I'm saying this is
a rank one matrix this is a rank one
matrix and so on and so forth so the way
you see that is as follows so u1 is a
column vector this is Sigma one times my
column vector u1 times my row vector v1
transpose
this is u1 v1 transpose plus sigma2
again column vector u - row vector V 2
transpose plus dot dot dot plus all the
way up to Sigma M column vector um row
vector V M transpose and so you can
you're probably used to computing vector
vector products like inner products
where you have a vector on its side
times a tall vector or something like
that this is called an outer product but
it's totally fine what you do this is a
matrix what you do is you take the first
element of u1 and you multiply the whole
vector v1 by that that's the first row
the next row is the second element of u1
times that whole row V 1 transpose and
so on and so forth you just go element
by element and you multiply this row by
that element this row by that element
this row by that element and so on and
so forth until you get a matrix now I
say it's rank 1 because that matrix by
construction has exactly 1 linearly
independent column and linearly
independent row every row and every
column of this matrix is dependent on
this row and this column so this is a
rank one matrix this is a rank one
matrix and so on and so forth ok so
that's another interpretation of the SVD
is that what you're doing is you're
decomposing X into these orthogonal
basis U and V where essentially you can
write this as a sum of these these rank
one matrices that increasingly improve
the approximation of X so if I only got
one vector U and one vector V the best
rank one approximation I can possibly
make to my matrix X is this one here
Sigma u 1 V 1 transpose if I get another
column of U and column of V I get to add
this Sigma u 2 V 2 transpose this is the
next best this is the best rank 2 matrix
that approximates X and the best rank
three and four and five are obtained by
keeping the first three or four or five
columns of U and V okay so that's that's
what this thing
value decomposition means and again
oftentimes what we'll do is we'll
truncate will truncate at rank R okay so
oftentimes if I have a lot of really
small singular values like let's say
Sigma R plus 1 and R plus 2 all the way
down to Sigma n are really really small
negligibly small and most of the
information of X is captured in the
first are singular values and singular
vectors and what I can do is I can chop
this summation off and I can throw away
all of the low energy singular values
and only keep the first R columns of U
and our columns of V and R by our sub
matrix
so let's now say that this is a little R
by the first R columns I keep a little R
by R and I keep the first our rows of V
transpose that we're going to define as
u tilde sigma tilde v tilde transpose
okay and here I've said that X is only
approximately equal to this because this
is a rank R approximation this is the
best approximation of X with a rank R in
terms of our column are linearly
dependent independent rows and columns
okay and in fact this has been
formalized in a theorem by Eckhart and
Jung so this is goes way back the
eckhart Young's theorem
eckhart young theorem and this is in
1936 so all of this theory goes way way
back over a hundred years for the the
singular value decomposition almost 100
years for the Eckhart Young theorem and
what it states is that the absolute best
approximation to the matrix X that has
rank R so the Arg min the best the best
X tilde such that rank
X tilde equals are the best X tilde that
minimizes X minus X tilde in the
Frobenius norm is given by and what are
mean min means is that whatever argument
minimizes this whenever X tilde does
have the smallest error and has rank R
is the output and that is exactly equal
to u tilde sigma tilde v tilde transpose
okay so the eckhart young theorem
essentially guarantees that the best
possible matrix approximation to X of
rank R is given by the first are
truncated singular value decomposition
you take the first our columns of u the
first our columns of V and the first
little R by r sub block of Sigma and you
can approximate this matrix X very
accurately and efficiently in terms of
those that truncated SVD okay very good
and we call this u tilde sigma tilde v
tilde in the book now one last thing i
want to point out is that before
remember this u and this v are actually
unitary this is an N by n matrix this is
an M by n matrix and if I multiply uu
transpose or u transpose u I get the
identity matrix but here if I if I
truncate at rank R if I throw away some
of the columns of U or V now these are
no longer square matrices and so this is
not exactly true anymore
it's still true that u tilde transpose u
tilde is the R by R identity matrix but
it is not true that u tilde u tilde
transpose this is not an identity matrix
ok so what was before truncation
but after truncating u transpose u is an
identity matrix but uu transpose is not
the identity matrix and this is really
really important
lots of us are guilty of forgetting this
basic basic fact
and having wrong proofs because we just
forgot that this is true I'm guilty of
this as well u transpose these columns
still orthogonal so if I take u tilde
transpose looks like this if you knock
these columns over on their side they're
these kind of short fat matrix times u
tilde these columns are still orthogonal
so if I a dot product them like this I
still get an identity matrix but now if
I construct this quantity u tilde u
tilde transpose this is a big n by n
square matrix of rank R and it's
definitely not equal to the identity
matrix okay good so just to recap we can
take our singular value decomposition
use Sigma V transpose and you can
essentially rearrange these columns and
this product into the some of these rank
one matrices Sigma 1 u 1 V 1 transpose
plus Sigma 2 u 2 V 2 transpose and so on
and so forth in general you only want to
do the economy SVD and keep the first M
columns of U and the first M sub block
of Sigma if you have tall skinny data
matrix and then even further sometimes
if you have small singular values you'll
truncate some of the the small singular
values and you'll get a rank or
approximation and it's provable that
this is the best rank our approximation
to the matrix X by the ekor young
theorem
okay so that's a lot going on here but
basically you can approximate your
matrix X in terms of a lower rank
approximate matrix X tilde given by a
truncated singular value decomposition
okay thank you